I don't know I always would say I'd get
a Chinese symbol like this was like my
big joke when I was like I'll get a
Chinese symbol that's a Chinese that
means Chinese symbol oh I was gonna get
one that was unoriginal I went to a
Chinese restaurant was like could you
guys like that's my research I went to
like a a and I asked him what is the
symbol for unoriginal and they like
couldn't give it to me
they didn't understand they have such a
stink yeah they kind of said that
[Music]
well Jews aren't allowed to have tattoos
right so my mother would always tell me
that but then she had her eyelids
she had permanent eyelids right so those
are tattooed as a team as a family I'm
good for radio your mom got makeup
tattooed I think is that's a tattoo
though it is definitely at that dude and
then she's like you can't have a tattoo
and there's like you have a tattoo I
live any of a facelift like you've
changed your whole no one even know if
you died you're different person I can't
have a tattoo like because I can't get
buried with it but her I heard that I
make up means like what were you giving
you were gonna get a what would you have
gotten if you wouldn't have helped I've
had to have heard telling me not to get
a tattoo I don't know what I would guy
and I would have probably gotten like my
grandpa's initials or something right
right
you know and I don't know like somewhere
on my forearm
I don't even know 8hg I guess Hg and
then there's a MC line or something some
big interview after she and Billy Bob
broke up and she said that when I
realized what I needed to break up with
him when I had gotten she had gotten his
like name tattooed on her and then she
was thinking I would never tattoo
Maddux's name her son her adopted son's
name on herself and then she's like why
did I tattoo his name why did I do Billy
Bob but I would never tattoo my son's
because I know I will always have a
relationship with my son yeah it's not
threatened and there was something
really interesting in that like if
you're somehow worried about a
connection with someone or you have an
insecurity about someone you tattoo
their name like Tamara and Winona Ryder
I'm Pete Davidson like official thing
I think even roof honestly marriage even
is like we're doing right I got you ever
okay I get it I mean I want that I've
that's so funny because with my ex when
we were never gonna get married I was
like I want to get tattoos like I wanted
something in writing on us that was like
we're bound for life like you find a way
you're so high we're gonna get tattoos
when you're special when you record it
we're gonna get matching ones right what
kind are you guys gonna get yeah what
are we getting again
she looks so - you were talking you
brought it up remember it's his joke
that we're gonna get matching tattoos to
celebrate my special which is I remember
one time Sabrina Jalees and I were gonna
get tattoos if we made it through on
Last Comic Standing
like past the semis we were like told
the cameras that NBC cameras really
we're gonna get tattoos tonight if we
get Last Comic Standing if we get past
her thank God we didn't because we would
have done it we would have done it and I
remember we were joking like what would
we get and greg Giraldo was one of the
judges and we were like we'll get Greger
oldest face tattooed on our ass what
happened it would be a nice tribute I
guess vinyls no I know we both got to
that night but no I did I maybe I don't
remember I just no no yes no yes would
you gather like the best-looking version
of Gregor like who picks the picture
like I don't know I would never have
gotten greg Giraldo space I mean it
would be more fitting now that he's gone
cuz like my step-brother has so many
tattoos and they all mean something he
has well he loves fishing
he's very soon he's a Miss Florida he
has a fish a rattlesnake his cousin that
died in a motorcycle accident his last
name and a wave like surfing and it's
like these are the exact thing and he
lives these things I just don't like
when I was talking about like the
accountant was like a skull that's
bleeding it's like you what is like that
one we went on two dates I just remember
he worked in the financial yeah stricter
on Wall Street or something he was in
estimate guy and he was fully tattooed
and and this whole double life kind of
is like a motorcycle guy with a beard
but he wore a suit every day three-piece
suit with a vest but he did ride a
motorcycle literally turned on by all
those tattoos you just described like I
like that I showed you my step-brother
like a purple like he's just like he
knows what he is leaning into it I like
it I take back everything I said about
tattoos
I either want them to have a ridiculous
story or I want them to be so meaningful
and stupid but also still stupid but
very meaningful stuff it's the same
thing as someone who had tattoos were
that when they were 18 and it meant
something like as long as there was a
funny story associated and like really
truly meant something to you I think
it's kind of a good thing like what he
has a wave cuz he just like to be like
surfing he like has a surfer him like
cutting back with like the splash of the
wave he has a bionic like I don't know
like he just the rattlesnakes badass and
his name is Jay I would date goes by
Jake the snake has a rattlesnake I mean
it's all there and it's coiled up ready
to attack and he would always get mad at
me if I miss platter yeah what else do I
love so much my phone Starbucks right
here Starbucks a magic wand just a
finger to finger there and then a blunt
to really show you know we're in a
ponytail that's when they know it yeah
and then you get weed inside your lips
so you say
I go through so many phases in life I'm
shocked that your cousin has always
liked these things cuz imagine if you
had tattooed stuff that you liked when
you really I wish I would mean that's
why I want to go get a Dave Matthews
tattoo now that's really like what you
would have had that had I like been
allowed to you can't get a freshie Dave
I would have had unicorns and ice skates
and ponies that's oh boy and now I feel
though forever I will always love the
things that I love now that's not true
that's huge that's great yeah well micro
penis right micro oh my dad people who
get tattoos on their penises or if you
get your clit pierced
no thank you I mean part of me wants to
just feel what it would feel like
getting it pierced I think that would be
a great feeling
it would be like painful but also like
probably pretty dope especially if you
get in the middle of the mall at a kiosk
[Laughter]
just get up on this chair here yeah I
don't mind the people in spencer's
that's the problem the guy who has to
pierce your that would be so weird
[Music]
you